in today's money watch we're looking at
how to talk to your kids about money
it's something parents have been doing
more frequently during the pandemic in
fact one survey found 47 percent of
parents spoke to their kids about money
at least once a week at the beginning of
2021. that's up from the previous four
years we wanted to know exactly what
kids think about money so we asked some
parents to grab their phones hit record
and just start asking questions here's
what nine-year-old lucy seven-year-old
gavin and sister savannah and addison
ages 8 and 11 had to say
what do you know about money
i know
that
a penny is worth one sentence what i
know about money is money doesn't make
you happy in life and the quarters
were
um
40 cents where does money come from your
job
[Music]
money comes from a money machine what do
you hear your mom and dad say about
money
they say like oh don't buy that too much
money oh save your money don't buy that
with your money save
save save save save save
what is a credit card a credit card is
the bank's money but you use
the debit card is your own money
a credit card is
a card with money you don't have to pay
with
how much do you think college costs
right now
7
000 something 100
100 what dollars
how much money do you want to have when
you grow up
one billion seven point
one hundred trillion enough
so like i don't wanna be like super
super bajillionaire rich
because then you're lonely
cbs news business analyst dollar dollar
jill schlesinger joins us good morning
good morning all right so let's talk
money money and kids what age should
parents start talking to their kids
about money research shows that a lot of
our money habits form as early as age
seven if you can believe it so that
means that you could actually start
having some conversations when they're
maybe three years old and you want to
identify coins you also want to give of
the concept of free versus what
something costs right it's free to go
play with your friend it costs money to
go buy a toy we also want to sort of
bring up this concept that they can wait
for something if they we don't have it
right away it's okay we can delay that
gratification so what happens if you
don't you just ignore it you say you
know my kids are too young before you
know it they're 18 and out of the house
okay here's the big problem we are all
flawed human beings right and we are
going to pass along a lot of our bad
habits and money habits are included and
so you really want to try to break some
of the chain so you don't want to talk
about money so much that you get your
kids freaked out you don't want to
saddle them with your issues you don't
want to not talk about it because they
do have to operate in the real world so
giving them some base knowledge is great
so again if you can just start to have
small conversations day-to-day
conversations as you go out and spend
money in the world sometimes a
generational curse could be the burden
of debt that a parent can pass down and
a lack of knowledge when it comes to
money what about allowance
it's controversial because i think in a
lot of families they say oh i'm going to
pay my kids to do chores and i think
experts really kind of have a problem
i'll raise my hand on that one jill yeah
you know why tell me what i'm doing
wrong okay cause your kids should just
do their chores they're part of your
household i think an allowance should be
based on something that you say to your
kids hey you know what i would buy you
these things they are frivolous things
they're fun things and i'm gonna give
you the money to make those choices
having an allowance allows you to have
more money conversations if you don't
want to pay an allowance that's okay too
this lesseners didn't pay their
daughter's allowances but you've got to
be able to introduce concepts of money
and talk about these issues again use
your day to day and remember because
money is emotional it isn't always just
about dollars and cents i have a 17 year
old and a 15 year old so is the
conversation different when you talk to
teens well i think that when kids get
into high school you can have a lot of
real conversations about money as early
as freshman year i think we talk about
college we talk about debt we talk about
saving we talk about some of their
spending and we introduce the concept of
debt and how you repay debt i think
that's a very good
piece of information to start breeding
in those high school years you mentioned
college what about college students what
should they keep in mind listen college
students have got to understand how to
manage their online savings and spending
practices and budgeting if they've got
school loans you know you've got to come
up with a way to repay those loans you
want to have them really check into
their credit histories every single
student should be looking at
annualcreditreport.com every year manage
that credit talk to your kids it
shouldn't be so scary there are other
scary topics i don't want to be an
expert on of course dollar dollar thanks
man you are the best thank you so much